and here to tell us a little more about
the opportunities technology like this
harbors is an expert from the fraunhofer
institute for wind energy and energy
system technology jachenbard thanks for
coming to join us on tomorrow today now
pump storage hydroelectric plants we're
seeing reinvigorated industrial
landscapes old mines that are suddenly
being reused surely there's a downside
to this technology
well it is an excellent idea we need
more energy storage in the future and
pump storage systems have a high
efficiency so
it is it is a great idea to to try and
reuse existing infrastructure
however we will need much more energy
storage in the future maybe a thousand
times more than what we have available
today in palm storage but it's a step in
the right direction well in a facility
like this
how much energy exactly is it producing
i mean just so that the viewers get an
idea for for how much is it enough for a
small town for a small city or well um
a pump storage power plant can provide
electricity for a city of the scale of
berlin for several hours so it's quite a
large amount of energy that can be
stored yeah that's quite impressive this
is the kind of solution that gender that
germany needs you know if it's going to
make this massive transition to
renewables the energy vendor now um that
they promised to carry out over the
coming decades on facebook our viewer
sato adriono says that supplying energy
from renewables
is actually simply a matter of will on
the part of governments do you agree
with that we certainly need a very
consistent energy policy over a number
of decades in order to achieve what what
our targets are but it is also depending
on the contribution of all people in the
country to save energy use new
technologies such as heat pumps electric
vehicles and so on well among the
different sustainable sources you know
you have hydroelectric power and solar
power wind power
just to name a few which do you think in
the long run is going to win out
the energy solution in the future will
not be one silver bullet it will not be
only one one uh supply system we will
have a mix of energy supply from solar
and wind which are the two most
important ones but also bioenergy plays
an important role because it can be
controlled
and there's other parts of the world who
have other opportunities geothermal
ocean energy uh hydropower when you talk
about bioenergy you're talking about
power to gas then power to gas or biogas
from fermentation process are the
options that we are currently looking at
um power storage for when the sun isn't
shining and the wind isn't blowing you
know this storing the energy that's
really a major problem hydroelectric
plants like the one in the report
they're one solution
what other kinds of solutions are out
there for storing large amounts of
energy on the scale we would need well
um
batteries electrochemical batteries like
lead-acid batteries or lithium-ion
batteries to name a new technology are
also very important for in the form of
electric vehicles or or
stationary systems in houses
and they will not be very big but we
will use very many of them other forms
are chemical storage systems
by using hydrogen or methane and that
can be
done by using the existing gas network
that we already have well supply is just
one aspect of this equation the other is
going to be consumer behavior what can
individuals do to actually improve this
sort of energy supply balance well
everybody can reduce the electricity
consumption by simply buying very
efficient appliances when you buy a new
fridge or you buy a new tv just pay
attention to the energy consumption we
have reduced our consumption at home by
maybe two thirds by now step by step wow
two-thirds that's a that's a lot
thank you very much for joining us on
tomorrow today